what's going on guys this is rob and for
this week's
versus video you guys decided to venture
outside the realms of both marvel and dc
and set up a battle between two
different takes on the evil superman
archetype with omniman from invincible
taking on homelander from the boys which
i guess was technically dc at one point
because it was published under the wild
storm imprint for a while but since it
was only for like six issues
it's really more closely associated with
dynamite comics who took over with issue
number seven than dc but yeah
i don't know i don't mean to get the
details
but anyway let's get into the origins
and powers of each of these guys and
figure out which of them
is the superior evil superman now
something i want to specify is i think
this might be one of these versus videos
that we throw up on the regular youtube
channel kind of public on the youtube
channel uh to kind of entice people and
show them the kind of stuff that we do
here on patreon and so because of that
and even though we're covering
invincible here on patreon
we haven't really gotten into the true
origin of omni man right there's the
version he told us
but you know believe half of what you
see in none of what you hear so
uh while there is the actual origin of
omniman here
in this this script we're going to skip
it right because i don't want to spoil
omniman's actual origin for you guys uh
so we'll just jump straight into his
powers so as far as his powers go omni
man's power set is very similar to
superman's which is to be expected since
he's based heavily on superman
and much like superman's powers are a
result of his kryptonian physiology omni
mans come from his viltrumite physiology
since viltrum is essentially just a
version of krypton
and the list of his powers is likely
exactly what you'd expect them to be
flight superhuman strength speed and
endurance invulnerability a healing
factor
nothing too surprising here now
viltromites are also able to hold their
breath for up to two weeks meaning they
can survive
within the vacuum of space and they age
at a much slower rate now in the
invincible universe there's no shortage
of superheroes operating on earth but
omniman is by far the strongest among
them so to put things into perspective
this universe had its own version of the
justice league called the guardians of
the globe which consisted of versions of
wonder woman martian manhunter flash
aquaman batman green lantern and yet
another version of superman called the
immortal but that was earth's premiere
superhero team and we all know what
happened to them if you're watching the
series
in the comics it happens a lot faster
but nonetheless right show's got to find
a way to build stuff out but we also saw
him with the ability to wipe out an
entire alien race
despite being significantly weakened at
the time so going up against omni man
we have homelander who was created by
garth ennis and derrick robertson
and first appeared in the boys number
three in 2006. now we're going to spoil
the heck out of out of this guy right
because if you haven't seen the boys by
now
i don't know what to tell you right i
mean that's that's your fault that
show's amazing so homelander was created
using dna from stormfront a superpowered
being from germany that became a member
of the
fuhrer's youth you guys know what i mean
we got to keep it friendly for youtube
and whose powers were greatly augmented
by a drug known as compound v
homelanders spent his youth in captivity
inside a laboratory where he was given
repeated doses of compound v to turn him
into a super soldier under the control
of a company called vaude american who
traced their roots back to world war
ii germany where they also tried to
create superheroes however the origin of
homelander as it was told by the company
to the general public was that he was an
alien that landed on earth so
literally superman's origin story but
because he is a partial clone of
stormfront
and because of the fact that he grew up
in a lab and was repeatedly subjected to
experimentation
homelanders pretty much a psychopath
devoid of morals and he's also mentally
unstable which results in him committing
some pretty unspeakable atrocities but
within the boy's universe he's the
leader of the seven which is the version
of that universe's justice league and is
a highly revered superhero to a public
that largely doesn't know his true
nature and if he thought omni man's
power set was similar to superman's
homelanders like dude hold my beer in
addition to flight superhuman strength
speed and durability homelander takes a
couple more pages out of the man of
steel's book and also possesses both
heat vision and x-ray vision so to get a
sense of how strong homelander is
we'll look at some of his feats from the
boys comic series including throwing a
jet with one hand
and casually lifting 800 pounds with
another now in terms of durability when
homelander was kept captive by blot
american
they kept him chained to a nuclear bomb
knowing that anything
short of that was unlikely to be a
threat his heat vision
is capable of cutting through opponents
in an instant and he was also capable of
bringing down an airplane
and so looking at homelanders feats here
it becomes clear pretty quickly
how this battle will play out homelander
is probably the most powerful super
being in his own universe
but the problem for him is that the
universe he comes from is just not on
the same scale as the invincible
universe invincible exists in a universe
that seems
to pretty closely mirror the universe we
find classic superheroes from the marvel
in dc
comics the boyz was created to be a
critique of the superhero genre and the
universe that garth inn has set up
is fairly close to the real world this
means that while the heroes of that
universe do some things that make them
look amazing
when compared to everyday people they
don't really have the insane feats that
heroes do in the invincible universe
there are no cosmic level threats no
villains capable of destroying galaxies
present in the boy's stories
because those aren't the kind of stories
that garth ennis set out to tell
but in invincible omniman is always
protecting earth from aliens that are
fully capable of bringing about its
destruction i mean
omniman single-handedly took out his
universe's justice league who are far
more powerful than their counterparts in
the boys universe so while this battle
is intriguing due to the fact that both
our combatants are presented as what
might happen if superman were evil
there's really no comparison here
an omni man would absolutely crush
homelander
in a fight that was never really even
fair to begin with
but yeah that's how i see that going
down guys uh but if you guys are new
here since we're putting this on the
public youtube channel if you guys are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core
patrons people who are part of patreon
make sure you guys keep an eye out for
the poll for next week's video right you
guys you guys know on patreon you guys
get to vote for the polls you're good to
vote for the versus battles keep an eye
out there
and uh and we'll keep the next one on on
patreon so anyway guys we're gonna bring
this to an end and i will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]
do
you